(children talking)
Salman: We do a lot of
virtual things on Khan Academy
and We Teach Science and
the goal of the summer camp
really is to give the students
a real physical experience
that really connects a lot of
the concepts that you might learn
on something like a Khan Academy video.
So we do things like real
engineering, we build Lego robots
that the students actually
write software for
that autonomously sumo wrestle,
we do market simulations,
we perform experiments but this all
involves indoor and outdoor activities.
We just do a bunch of
stuff that really connects
a lot of the abstract conceptual
things that you might learn
on say a Khan Academy video and then
you bring it into the classroom.
So in the market simulations,
students learn about probability,
they learn about gain theory,
they learn about trading.
In the robotics they learn about
engineering, they learn about math,
they do a lot of trigonometry
and geometry so we really try
to make it all very
tangible for the students.
Aragon: So this is mental boot camp 2010.
It's a one week course held in
Portola Valley in the Bay area
for about 20 to 25 students ranging
from 6th grade to roughly 9th grade.
Spend a week exploring math and science
and technology in the real world.
What you're seeing today
is a big part of our course
which is the robotics portion and
we're using the Lego Mindstorm NXT's
and we've given the kids a
challenge for the week to make
a sumo wrestling robot and they're
designed to fight on these wooden tables
that you see, one-on-one, and the idea is
to push your fellow robot off the edge.
So they're using a variety
of tools within the robots,
there are sensors to detect
when you've fallen off the edge,
there are other things like the
motors that drive them around
and then they've got actuators to hammer
on each other and push each other off.
So that's the main thrust of the week.
We're spending half of
the time doing robotics
and then the other half
we're doing board games,
we're doing the math behind board games,
probability and statistics, game theories.
The kids are also learning
about markets and for example,
trading markets and how they work.
Rahul: Hi, I'm Rahul.
Lance: And I'm Lance.
Rahul: And this week we're building
a Lego NXT robot for our project.
Lance: The goal is to push the
opponent's robot off the table
before your robot falls off.
Rahul: We can do that by
making ultrasonic sensor-
Lance: It goes and tries to look for it.
Rahul: Yeah and there's a
light sensor to make sure
it doesn't fall off the table and also
here we have a motion track sensor
so that when it backs up it
doesn't fall off the table
because the ultrasonic sensor's facing
that way and so is the light sensor,
that's why we stuck a
track sensor back here.
We also have some wheels
and these are our motors.
Lance: This isn't working
very well but it's a whacker.
It just kind of whacks the opponent's
robots to try and disassemble it
or push it or knock it
off balance or something.
Rahul: And here we can try to motion.
Lance: I'm just going to run the program.
(robot sounds)
(children laughing)
Voiceover: Your robot still won.